ANTHONY MAYS: Welcome to
Engineering Everyday Equity.
I'm Anthony D. Mays,
software engineer
on the data visualization
team here at Google.
In this series, we
discuss practical ways
in which we can build equity,
diversity, and inclusion
into the product design process.
And in this episode
specifically, we're
going to talk about the
understanding phase.
And so I would love to
introduce to you Livvie,
who's going to help
us talk through what
the "understand
phase" is, and how
we can use some practical
tips to really understand
what the problem is.
Thanks, Livvie, for
being here with us today.
LIVVIE LIN: Thank you.
Happy to be here.
ANTHONY MAYS: In
our last episode,
I had the great pleasure
of hosting Lea Coligado
and we talked about the nuances
between equity, diversity,
and inclusion.
We also talked about practical
ways in which we can involve
stakeholders into the process,
such as by encouraging
executive buy-in, and allyship
And we also talked about things
like inviting folks
from diverse backgrounds
into the product discussion, so
perhaps hold lightning talks.
One of the things that I find
sort of difficult to understand
is how I can better
get stakeholders
involved in the design process.
Do you know what I mean?
LIVVIE LIN: Yeah, I
know what you mean.
That can definitely
be a challenge.
Because we're really trying
to balance let's push out
new features, but let's
also take the resources
to have diversity,
and inclusion,
and make things accessible.
I'm an accessibility
champion on my team.
And I'm lucky to
have other people who
also value diversity, inclusion,
and accessibility on the team
as well.
And together, I
think we mostly serve
to remind the
executive stakeholders
and people about the importance
of having this as a value.
And beyond that, I
was born and raised
in the Pacific Northwest.
I'm Asian.
I'm the child of
immigrant parents.
And I also identify as
queer and non-binary.
I think it's amazing
how diverse my team is.
We have people who are different
ages, who have different work
experiences, different
backgrounds, race, gender,
and even different
working styles.
And I think everyone
brings something
different to the table.
And it's really great that
it's a safe place for people
who have different
perspectives to be
able to share their ideas.
I also feel like
I've learned a lot
from being an
accessibility champion,
in terms of just being
more cognizant of people
with different abilities.
But it's really about being able
to see my work through someone
else's eyes.
ANTHONY MAYS: Well,
yeah, I really
appreciate you saying
that, seeing your work
through other people's eyes.
Because as someone who
is a black man, who's
come from Compton, and
who's also Christian,
I really think it's
important that people in tech
understand the unique
background from which I come,
and for other people
that I know, and have met
in this industry
who are different
and don't fit the
traditional background.
So I can really
appreciate that it's
difficult to think
about empathy,
and to really practice that.
It can be challenging at times.
LIVVIE LIN: I'm glad that
I'm at a place where people
are able to share their
ideas, and I'm just
able to learn, and just learn
more about other people.
Because everyone has a story,
and something to teach,
and something to learn.
ANTHONY MAYS: So in terms of
talking about these ideas,
I want to bring this home
to a hypothetical app
that I have called Scholar.
And it's a hypothetical
app right now,
but the more I talk
about it, the more I
think I should spend some 20%
time, and try to get it done.
But before we do that,
let's talk about the ABCs
of inclusive product design.
The ABCS of inclusive
product design
are, A, address diverse needs
of current and future users.
Though you may
have a target user,
who else could possibly
be using your app?
From what country
do they hail from?
What kind of
educational background
do they have or
access to technology?
B, build for everyone,
with everyone.
In addressing those
diverse user needs,
does your team reflect
some of that diversity?
If your team is not diverse, you
are bound to have blind spots.
C, continuously
test and improve.
Through iteration
and debugging, you
may find your product
is not as inclusive
as you had originally thought.
Did it somehow not consider
men and women, and the spectrum
of gender identities?
Does it exclude people from
different locations, beliefs,
or backgrounds?
In various ways, we'll be
returning to these concepts.
It's good to revisit
them to ask yourself
those high-level questions
that drive design functionality
along with important
questions of what problem
you are solving for, and what
is your underlying mission.
Establishing the ABCs can become
second nature to your process.
So now that we know
about the ABCs,
I want to talk a little
bit about this app
that I want to build.
So again, the app
is called Scholar.
And it's designed to
connect high school
students who are graduating
with schools and scholarships.
And so it's sort of designed
like a dating app for students,
that can help them connect
with the institutions
of their choice, and understand
more about what scholarship
opportunities are available.
In the previous discussion
that I had with Lea,
we talked about
some practical tips
for baking in
diversity and inclusion
into the design sprint process.
And so now we want
to talk about,
or I'd like to talk about,
understanding the problem.
Are there some
practical tips that you
can give me in that area?
LIVVIE LIN: So the first
part of the sprint,
this "understand
phase," where we really
get to get into the
heads of the users,
and together try to gain
an understanding of who
our users are, and how we can
make this product for them.
We listen to lightning talks.
And lightning talks
are essentially
where we are hearing
different perspectives of how
this app might be used,
and getting a better
understanding of the product.
So the note-taking
process of this
is we're going to be
taking sticky notes.
And we have blank sticky notes
where we write HMW on the top.
And HMW stands for How Might We.
And this is how we can
start reframing pain
points of our users, and
turn them into opportunities.
ANTHONY MAYS: Well,
that's excellent.
That's a great idea.
Matter of fact, as it turns
out, got some HMWs already ready
to go.
LIVVIE LIN: Oh, awesome.
Let's take a look.
ANTHONY MAYS: So all right,
here are a few that I have.
How might we demystify the
college application process?
Also, how can we make it easier
for high school counselors
to connect with their students?
And then also wanted
to know about how
we might help colleges
reach students
beyond just looking at their
SAT scores or their GPA.
LIVVIE LIN: Awesome.
This looks like a really good
start to some How Might Wes.
Is it OK if I make
some suggestions?
ANTHONY MAYS: Absolutely.
LIVVIE LIN: Awesome.
So here you have, how might we
make it easier on high school
counselors?
Well, I was recently reading an
article about how it can really
help students to start the
conversation about college
earlier, maybe
even middle school.
It can really turn, "Well,
are you going to college?"
into, "Where are you
going to college?"
Make it more of a sure thing.
So what if we expand the
audience to younger ages,
as well?
ANTHONY MAYS: No,
I really like that.
Matter of fact, I've got sticky
notes and marker right here.
LIVVIE LIN: And maybe
another suggestion
could be, for
another How Might We,
how might we start the
conversation on financial aid
and merit-based scholarship?
As a general piece
of advice, I would
say that you want to think
of a diverse group when we're
thinking about How Might Wes,
and call out if someone thinks
that a How Might We might be
relevant to too narrow a group
or might be too homogeneous.
ANTHONY MAYS: So
you're saying that I
should think about
how to stretch it out
to a larger group.
LIVVIE LIN: Yeah.
So next, shifting
gears a little bit,
we're going to talk about
criteria for success.
I would say when making
your criteria for success,
go ahead and set some
inclusive criteria.
So have you thought
about any of that?
ANTHONY MAYS: Yeah,
no, of course.
I want to change the
world, so there's that.
But here's what I'm thinking--
I'm thinking that
30% of my new users
should be first-generation
college students.
In the challenge statement
that I talked about
with Lea earlier,
we talked about how
it would be great to build
an app in 2018 that connects
high school students with
the colleges and scholarships
that they need,
and to specifically
focus on first-generation
college students.
So I'd love to see 30%
of my new user base
be first-generation
college students.
I think it'd also be great--
piling on top of that--
having an additional
10% of new users,
say, who are outside of the
normal college age of 16 to 18.
LIVVIE LIN: Yeah,
I'm liking how we're
expanding and diversifying
the user base right here.
I also see that you have
a How Might We help people
with disabilities,
and just in general,
making sure that college
admissions process is
more inclusive.
So I would say, maybe we could
think about some criteria
in terms of making sure we give
specific call-outs to colleges
that have good diversity
ratings or strong student
life for underrepresented
minorities.
ANTHONY MAYS: OK, yeah, so
I see what you're saying.
You're saying that I
can also use this app
to incentivize institutions
that focus on diversity
and inclusiveness,
and sort of give them
a pat on the back to help
encourage them to do it more.
LIVVIE LIN: Yeah, sure.
ANTHONY MAYS: Thank you,
Livvie, for joining us today.
I really appreciate
your wisdom and insights
and helping us with the
understand phase of the product
design process.
So great having you.
LIVVIE LIN: Yeah, thank
you for having me.
I had a really great time.
And I'd love to hear
more about Scholar.
Keep me posted.
ANTHONY MAYS: Of
course, you know I will.
So let's just
review real quickly.
We talked about the ABCs
of the inclusion process--
A, addressing the
needs of not just
our current users,
but also future users.
And we talked about B, building
for everyone, and lastly, C,
continuously testing
and improving
on what we're building.
So those are great ABCs.
We also talked about HMWs,
How Might Wes, and thinking
about how to keep from
making them too specific
so that we're focusing just on
a homogeneous group of users,
but really expanding
to think about all
the potential users that might
be interested and able to use
this app.
We also talked about making
the criteria for success
as inclusive as possible.
Thank you for joining us on this
episode of Engineering Everyday
Equity.
If you'd like to learn more
about how to build more equity,
diversity, and inclusion in your
company or products practices,
feel free to visit the link
in the description below.
If you have a question,
drop that in the Comments.
And make sure to tune
in for our next episode,
where we're going to
talk about the validation
phase of design sprint process.
Thanks a lot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]